le sénateur maire de Lyon Gérard Collomb
est l'invité de Preuves par 3 au moment
où l'ail le droit du PS le pôle des
réformateurs donne de la voix et bien
sûr Gérard Collomb veut faire entendre
ses positions face au frondeur et à
Martine Aubry bonjour bonjour vous direz
dans un instant Karine Perret de
l'Agence France Presse notre partenaire
comme chaque semaine pour cette émission
avec Dailymotion quel est donc votre
réponse au réquisitoire
anti-gouvernement de Martine Aubry qui
appelle un changement de politique moins
libéral père internaute à la fin de
l'émission à la tête du Grand Lyon vous
êtes bien sûr confronté à la baisse des
dotations publiques vous avez votre
opinion sur la traite débattue réformes
territoriale le Grand Lyon Gérard
Collomb c'est aussi le couloir de la
chimie la raffinerie de feyza et vous
connaissiez forcément Christian de
Marjorie le patron total oui je suis
allé l'occasion avec lui de discuter de
l'avenir de la chimie en France parce
que nous sommes très concernés et donc
évidemment total et des un des
principaux acteurs et nous avions
discuté avec lui des coûts de production
par exemple des thylines à partir de la
raffinerie de Feyzin du vapo cracker et
donc de ce que ça entraînait pour toute
l'industrie qui se trouvait en aval
c'était quelqu'un qui ne marchait pas
ses mots qui avaient une vision assez
précise de ce qu'il voulait faire de son
groupe de la place de son groupe dans le
monde qui est en même temps était très
attaché à la France très patriotique et
donc qui voulait que son entreprise qui
a une grande multinationale et en même
temps ses racines profondément ancrées
en France sans doute pas dans le couloir
de la chimie mais vous l'avez noté en
France totale est une entreprise qui est
décrié vous le déplorez
je crois qu'évidemment total avait eu
une mauvaise image de marque avec des
phénomènes comme l'Erika mais justement
je pense que de Marjorie avait essayé de
changer cette image et donc de faire en
sorte que petit à petit total est une
image plus positive et on n'a pas
tellement de grands groupes comme Total
en France et les groupes qui sont
internationaux comme cela il vaut mieux
les garder parce qu'il avait vu en vous
un allié dans son combat pour les gaz de
schiste alors c'est un problème dont on
avait discuté ensemble lui il était très
engagé moi ce que j'ai ce que j'ai
toujours dit c'est que en tout cas il
fallait pas se refuser la capacité à
analyser les choses à faire des études
et des recherches avant de passer
évidemment à la phase active vous voyez
j'arrive j'arrive du Canada il y a
quelques quelques temps donc vous savez
que les gaz de schiste au Canada sont à
la fois donc recherchés mais en même
temps qu'ils ont des éléments d'analyse
et on voit ce qu'il y a de positif ça
booste l'économie mais en même temps il
peut y avoir quelques problèmes
écologiques en tout cas il faut soupeser
l'un et l'autre sans a priori et donc
essayer de regarder ce qui est bon pour
notre pays alors on va voir maintenant
quelles sont les réformes qui ont été
engagées celles que vous soutenez bien
sûr Gérard Collomb c'est le qui ont
tardé d'ailleurs puisque vous aviez
déclaré il y a quelques temps que
François Hollande avait perdu les deux
premières années de son quinquennat
d'abord j'ai deux photos à vous proposer
regardez Martine Aubry voilà et Emmanuel
Macron qui incarne pour vous le
socialisme moderne si vous voulez ça
fait un beau couple chacun avec ses
caractéristiques mais je pense que c'est
pas mal on peut montrer ça effectivement
aux caméras je pense que il y a
peut-être un couple ouais je pense que
ça peut ça doit pouvoir le faire
ils peuvent s'accorder bon on en
discutera sur le fond mais il est
nécessaire évidemment que demain il y a
une majorité pour le gouvernement et
donc Martine Aubry comme elle l'a dit je
crois ce matin puisse appuyer le
gouvernement alors donc le ministre de
l'Économie Emmanuel Macron c'est lui qui
incarne le socialisme moderne dans tous
les cas pour le New York Times ce qui
lui a consacrer un portrait assez long
récemment
donc il milite pour déverrouiller le
pays vous approuvez tout ce qui
s'apparente pour beaucoup à une potion
amère
je ne suis pas sûr que ça soit une
potion amère parce que vous voyez si
effectivement on continue sur la
trajectoire dans laquelle on est
c'est-à-dire la perte de la
compétitivité la perte de nos industries
et bien petit à petit d'un point de vue
social on ne pourra plus porter de
grands projets et donc pour moi il n'y a
pas de coupure entre la dynamique
économique et l'ambition sociale qui
doit continuer
un grand pays comme la France le travail
le dimanche vous êtes pour de longues
dates quand même alors sur le travail de
dimanche moi je suis pour qu'on autorise
effectivement le travail le dimanche et
il se trouve que sur Lyon on y réfléchit
on y pense on va étendre le travail le
dimanche à l'ensemble de l'agglomération
lyonnaise parce que je sais que cela
pourrait nuire à un certain nombre de
petits commerces dans les quartiers mais
sur les endroits par exemple
touristiques de Lyon oui on y réfléchit
et donc ce qu'on dit c'est que le
gouvernement pourrait donner
l'autorisation et qu'ensuite par un
accord entre la préfecture les maires
des grandes agglomérations et puis les
représentants des chambres de commerce
et le métier on pourrait finaliser un
accord ambition sociale la réforme de
l'assurance chômage et lorsque je
regarde moins longtemps notamment le
cadre lorsque je regarde par exemple ce
qui se passe dans des pays comme la
Suède qu'est-ce qu'ils font où il y a un
taux de chômage relativement bas par
rapport à la France qu'est-ce qu'ils
font 1 ils font de la formation beaucoup
plus qu'en France et donc la
reconversion dans les périodes de
chômage et beaucoup plus financée 2 il
donne des financements qui sont
importants dans les premiers mois donc
du chômage mais ensuite effectivement la
période est plus courte pour inciter à
reprendre le travail je crois que il
faut effectivement faire cette double
réforme ce genre d'arguments tout de
suite les arguments pleuvent plus proche
c'est la chasse au chômeurs oui je
l'entends mais si vous voulez voyez en
France on est ceux qui avons sur le
papier les lois les plus justes la
protection des salariés la plus encadrée
c'est vrai par exemple pour les jeunes
c'est vrai pour les chômeurs et puis
quand on regarde les fêtes on s'aperçoit
par exemple que sur le CDI c'est très
encadré mais par contre il y a plus de
CDI aujourd'hui qui se font sur le
chômage théoriquement c'est très protégé
mais c'est le pays où les jeunes
n'arrivent plus à trouver un emploi ou
les seigneurs n'arrivent plus à trouver
un emploi donc on s'aperçoit que ce qui
apparaît juste d'un point de vue
théorique et ben dans la réalité se
traduit par exactement le contraire de
ce qu'on recherche ce sont de fausses
protections sociales si je veux
comprendre j'ai l'impression quand même
Gérard Collon que l'arrivée d'Emmanuel
Macron à Bercy encore plus libéré votre
parole ah non moi j'ai toujours porter
ce genre de parole vous savez vous vous
souvenez on m'avait invité pour un livre
que j'avais écrit il y a trois ou quatre
ans je disais et si la France éveillée
c'était le titre du livre et où
je disais à l'époque attention le Parti
socialiste est dans l'irréalité la plus
totale s'il continue comme ça on va
avoir de grands problèmes et je crois
que deux ans sans réforme de fond nous a
amené à une période de grande difficulté
de la réalité du principe de réalité
mais Martine Aubry estime qu'il ne faut
pas renoncer à son idéal pour
transformer le réel est-ce que vous en
tant militant d'une socialiste vous avez
pu vous interroger sur la perte de votre
idéal face à la réalité genre je crois
que elle a elle a raison Martine Aubry
il faut pas perdre de vue son idéal vous
voyez si je regarde par exemple dans mon
agglomération ou comme vous le savez on
est assez en phase avec le monde
économique ça nous permet justement
d'avoir suffisamment de moyens pour
redéployer les quartiers pour faire en
sorte qu'il n'y ait plus de séparation
spatiale et de séparation sociale entre
les différents quartiers de la ville de
porter des opérations de rénovation
urbaine donc pour moi je vous l'ai dit
au niveau local comme au niveau national
l'économie et le social sont liées
d'accord alors on a passé en revue
quelques réformes il y en a d'autres
encore par exemple la fin des solides
sociaux pour les entreprises
on dit que ça peut pousser les patrons à
embaucher plus facilement s'il ne doit
pas créer de comité d'entreprise etc
d'avoir des délégués du personnel vous
êtes pour il est clair que le passage du
seuil est quelque chose d'extrêmement
difficile on lisserait un peu que cela
ne serait pas plus mal une autre
question les 35 heures la Dame des 35
heures Martine Aubry est-ce que vous
êtes pour des dérogations par branche
voire par usine vous savez je pense
qu'aujourd'hui il y a eu une modulation
qui s'est faite partout et que dans les
entreprises beaucoup de gens ont déjà
passé un accord sur les 35 heures donc
pour moi je n'en pas puisque c'est un
comme on dit aujourd'hui marqueur je
n'en fais pas un problème particulier on
va encore vous dire c'est encore Martine
Aubry on va pas la citer tout au long de
l'émission quand même Gérard Collomb
mais que vous évoquez les vieilles je
pense que à Lille et que elle porte
aussi une capacité de se développer avec
les entreprises quand même bien sûr on
en parlera peut-être
absolument on parlera de l'implication
politique effectivement de ces deux
lignes qui s'affichent et qui
s'affirment aujourd'hui encore plus mais
elle dit que tout ce que vous venez
d'évoquer toutes ces réformes en fait ce
ne sont que des vieilles recettes
libérales
voyez je pense que le monde le monde a
changé aujourd'hui ce qui fait peut-être
nos différences mais on anticipe
peut-être d'autres questions c'est que
nous nous pensons que nous sommes dans
un monde globalisé et donc on peut pas
appliquer les recettes de la
social-démocratie traditionnelle qui se
développait dans un cadre national et
donc tout l'enjeu pour le Parti
socialiste et justement comment savoir
porter un idéal dans le cadre d'une
économie qui est une économie globale et
donc comment faire pour que concrètement
dans la vie de tous les jours les
réformes que l'on porte et bien puissent
bénéficier aux gens tout simplement donc
pas plus c'est fini le social démocratie
traditionnel donc vous vous assumez
comme social
je voulais vous dire social libéral non
ça c'est encore un terme qui fait peur
le libéralisme est connoté en France si
par exemple c'est effectivement le
marché juste le marché ce n'est pas
comme cela que je fonctionne dans ma
ville voyez par exemple les grands
projets d'urbanisme ils se font pas
simplement par le jeu du marché et se
font avec une définition de la puissance
publique de la même manière si vous
voulez je ne laisse pas le marché
réguler totalement d'un point de vue
immobilier des constructions que nous
réalisons parce que je sais qu'on peut
aboutir à des bulles spéculatives donc
on régule mais on sait que par contre il
doit y avoir un travail très proche
entre d'une part la puissance publique
et d'autre part les entreprises privées
une réforme du gouvernement que vous
contestez je pense à celle des
allocations familiales il y a un peu
plus d'un an Gérard Collomb vous aviez
mis en garde avec la réforme du quotient
familial moins avantageux pour certaines
familles les plus éditants
quand on risque de baisse la natalité
dans notre pays aujourd'hui
c'est à tester c'est la fin donc de
l'universalité des allocations
familiales est-ce que vous le déplorez
est-ce que vous avez craignez
effectivement un risque pour la natalité
dans notre pays surtout si vous voulez
je me dis que on fait des choses qui
sont un peu contraires parce que on va
demander par exemple à la Caisse
nationale d'allocations familiale de
financer beaucoup la réforme des rythmes
scolaires ce qui va coûter très très
cher une réforme que très peu de gens
demandaient dans notre pays et puis par
contre on va tailler effectivement dans
les allocations familiales ou là
beaucoup de gens pensent qu'il faut
continuer sur la même voix sur
l'universalité moi je suis plutôt sur le
principe d'universalité donc voilà donc
vous contestez cette réforme qui a été
je le dis sous le double aspect rythme
scolaire et donc
universalité qui sont des aspects de
financement et l'un et l'autre on a tort
d'avoir fait l'une et d'avoir fait l'eau
donc et vous craignez effectivement une
baisse de la natalité qui pourrait en
décoller même si les couples ne font pas
des enfants bien sûr pour les
allocations pour les aides sociales
néanmoins bien sûr mais quand même ça
aide et on voit bien que aujourd'hui une
de nos principales de nos principaux
points forts par rapport à l'Allemagne
c'est justement notre démographie si sur
ce point-là qui nous permet d'envisager
l'avenir avec plus de sérénité là aussi
tout d'un coup on s'a fait il y aura des
difficultés pour l'avenir vous ne
voterez pas c'est très forme là du
financement on va essayer de faire
changer encore le gouvernement si c'est
possible d'accord très bien et là vous
donnez raison à Martine Aubry qui dit le
cap n'est pas bien défini c'est le cas
sur les allocations familiales puisque
la réforme a changé brutalement ce que
je dis moi je dis il faut suivre une
seule ligne et ne pas avoir des mesures
qui sont contradictoires on parlera tout
à l'heure des des collectivités locales
on peut pas leur demander en même temps
de faire des économies puis en même
temps de faire des dépenses c'est l'un
ou l'autre ça peut pas être les deux en
même temps très bien alors on va parler
plus avant de politique donc maintenant
avec Karen Perret de l'Agence France
Presse qui va nous rejoindre pour
évoquer donc l'impact de votre
mobilisation avec les réformateurs
voyons d'abord quels sont vos troupes
exactement avec ce reportage et sans
quête cette enquête signée Jérôme Rabier
ils ne sont qu'une trentaine de
parlementaires à s'en revendiquer et
pourtant c'est bien la ligne politique
du pôle des réformateurs du PS qui est
actuellement appliqué par le
gouvernement pour Christophe carrèche
co-fondateur du mouvement la question
des réformes ne devrait même pas se
poser le coût aujourd'hui de la
non-réforme est un coût faramineux pour
la France un cercle de réflexion très
actif pour faire avancer ses idées mais
qui agit en marge du parti capable aussi
de s'opposer frontalement au premier
secrétaire notamment sur le sujet des
allocations chômage il n'y a pas de
tabou à gauche il y a des totems pour
nous il n'y a pas de tabou
les tabous ils sont sans doute du côté
de ceux qui ont participé notamment nous
explique que il ne faut toucher à aucun
acquis les premiers visés sont bien sur
les frondeurs le problème pour le pôle
des réformateurs c'est qu'ils sont moins
nombreux une trentaine face à 45
frondeurs à l'assemblée qui vont par
exemple obtenir sur le prochain budget
et qui réclame qu’une minorité n'impose
pas sa vision c'est un peu un problème
de se dire finalement que la ligne qui
est appliquée aujourd'hui dans la
politique gouvernementale était
minoritaire dans le Parti socialiste par
exemple au moment de la primaire de 2011
ça montre que le gouvernement s'est
décentré par rapport à ce qu'il faisait
le fond commun de valeur d'analyses du
Parti socialiste et je pense que c'est à
l'origine aussi d'une partie des
difficultés que nous connaissons
aujourd'hui en l'absence de congrès du
PS depuis l'élection de François
Hollande impossible de savoir quel est
l'opinion majoritaire dans le parti même
si les critiques sont plus audibles
quand vous êtes au sein du Parti
socialiste c'est beaucoup plus facile
d'aller de sur la place publique en
professant des idées de type flaphonde
que de le faire avec des idées de type
rapport Gallois par rapport à votre base
électorale il y a un des deux
positionnement qui est beaucoup plus
confortable après avoir imposé ces idées
au sommet de l'État le pôle des
réformateurs doit prouver qu'il
représente une majorité au moins au sein
du PS c'est à et qu'il gagnera sa
légitimité voilà Karine Perret de la
fête avec nous bonsoir Karine
des représentants émérite de ce pôle des
réformateurs monsieur Colomb une
trentaine de parlementaires dans ce pôle
c'est finalement pas très peur qui était
présent à Lyon pour la réunion que l'on
a tenu il y a quelques semaines mais il
y a beaucoup plus effectivement de
parlementaire je sais pas on n'a pas
fait signer encore aujourd'hui mais on
est à mon avis beaucoup plus nombreux et
dans les temps qui viennent on verrait
effectivement que nous représentons un
courant important tout simplement parce
que je crois qu'il n'y a pas
d'alternative à ce que nous proposons
vous savez les économistes qui
travaillent avec nous c'est des gens
comme Philippe Paillon comme Eli Cohen
c'était l'ensemble des économistes qui
par exemple pour la primaire avait
soutenu donc François Hollande et je me
souviens d'une réunion à la maison de
numérique latine où ils étaient tous
présents et où il disait ce qu'il
fallait faire ce n'est pas ce qui a été
fait pendant les deux premières années
puis on s'est aperçu que les choses ne
marchaient pas qu'il fallait prendre un
tournant et à partir de là effectivement
je crois aujourd'hui mais depuis peu de
temps il y a donc une ligne qui est
suivie qui se rapproche de ce que nous
pouvons penser et vous pensez que cette
ligne est majoritaire aux parties
socialiste je sais pas si elle est
majoritaire partie socialiste je n'en
sais rien
qui disent chacun nous on représente la
vraie gauche donc qui croient enfin qui
est majoritaire aujourd'hui il y a pas
effectivement il y a pas de congrès
pour ceux qui me concernent mais je
prétends parler au nom de personne je
pèse pas le problème en torrent de en
terme de savoir qui est majoritaire qui
est minoritaire je me pose le problème
sur savoir ce qui est bon pour la France
aujourd'hui il est soutenu
majoritairement par les députés donc on
verra si ça change moi en tout cas ce
que je souhaite c'est qu'on continue sur
une ligne qui est la seule effectivement
avec capable d'empêcher que l'on puisse
continuer à perdre des parts de marché
que l'on voit notre compétitivité
baissée et que petit à petit parce que
il y a des régions entières qui sont en
train de se paupériser par le défaut de
leurs industries bah on voit des gens de
plus en plus au chômage ou en situation
préc parce que le socialisme c'est quand
même penser à cela pensez à faire en
sorte que les gens ne soient pas
chômeurs pensaient qu'il n'est pas des
emplois précaires à mon avis c'est ça le
socialisme appliqué à la réalité et ce
texte là que vous avez lancé le
manifeste de des réformateurs vous
entendez en faire une contribution au
prochain congrès du PS avec Manuel Valls
on verra nous on continue à essayer de
développer notre pensée j'écoutais ce
qui était dit tout à l'heure
par votre observateur il avait raison de
dire que c'est plus difficile de
défendre une ligne Gallois qu'une ligne
en disant on va augmenter les salaires
on va encore raccourcir la durée de la
retraite on va bon mais sauf que c'était
Inna est totalement irréaliste et donc
nous on essaye de dire voilà si la
France veut demain à nouveau rayonner
dans le monde il faut suivre cette ligne
là vous voyez moi je vais souvent à
l'étranger et je conseille certain
nombre de nos amis d'aller un peu
partout dans le monde lorsque l'on
regarde par exemple comment les
États-Unis sont en train de redémarrer
comment du côté de l'Asie il y a une
dynamique extraordinaire dans tous les
domaines si demain nous sommes
incapables d'innover dans nos
entreprises dans tous les domaines qui
vont se développer demain que ça soit
les sciences du vivant les
biotechnologies les clean tech etc nous
allons avoir de grandes difficultés et
la France deviendra un pays de deuxième
zone vous vous dites réforme réformes il
faut faire des réformes Martine Aubry
par exemple ce week-end dans sa
contribution dit
des réformes oui mais des réformes de
gauche donc vous vous opposez forcément
c'est pas possible de
mais il faut essayer après de pouvoir
avoir un équilibre mais en tout cas moi
je pense que le débat doit avoir lieu
pas simplement sur quelques lignes mais
sur le fond vous voyez des gens comme
Philippe Aguillon qui ont par exemple
publié un livre repensé l'état de quoi
il s'inspire il se trouve qu'un certain
nombre de pays la Suède par exemple le
Canada l'Australie se trouvait dans une
situation telle qu'elle est la France à
la fois d'être publique énorme déficit
public manque de compétitivité manque
d'innovation qu'ils ont fait un certain
nombre de réformes et que tout d'un coup
ils ont rebondi lorsque l'on regarde
aujourd'hui la dynamique qui existe au
Canada vous voyez moi j'étais donc il y
a 15 jours je voyais tous les jeunes
Français qui étaient partis pour monter
des startups au Canada et je me disais
quand même que c'était dommage qu'on
n'ait pas été capable de garder ses
talents en France
étrangers envoyez beaucoup d'atouts à
l'étranger il y en a quand même en
France des atouts alors ou alors à vous
écouter
on a surtout un poids mort en France et
le Parti socialiste
vous voyez par exemple dans notre dans
notre agglomération l'année dernière on
a réussi à avoir 77 nouvelles
entreprises étrangères tout simplement
parce que ils savent que l'on chez vous
qui sont bien accueillis et puis surtout
qu'on a réussi à développer des pôles
d'innovation on est à peu près les
premiers ou les 2e en France sur les
sciences du vivant on n'est pas trop
mauvais sur les clean tech je crois que
sur le numérique le franc le plan French
tech que nous avons un écosystème qui
comprend déjà 38 000 personnes
c'est-à-dire une masse critique
importante et elle se disent que c'est
pas mal de s'implanter dans le phare de
de la France on a fait si vous voulez je
m'aperçois qu'au niveau français quand
l'an dernier on voyait une chute des
investissements étrangers en France nous
on avait réussi à avoir une hausse des
investissements étrangers
selon vous quel est son avenir politique
pourquoi est-ce qu'elle est on l'a
entendu sortir vraiment de son silence
ce week-end à ce qu'elle vise Matignon
en cas d'échecs aux élections de 2015
est-ce qu'elle vise une nouvelle
primaire peut-être pour faire barrage
qu'il faudrait le demander
je pense que Martine Aubry elle
développe un certain nombre d'idées
depuis toujours moi je le reconnais je
l'ai dit une chose c'est la cohérence
dans la pensée ce qu'elle dit
aujourd'hui elle le disait déjà il y a 4
ans moi ce que se dit aujourd'hui je le
disais aussi il y a quatre ans je
passais les vieilles recettes mais en
tout cas chacun a une ligne qui est
différente effectivement entre les deux
lignes il faut brancher en tout cas
ce qui est mieux c'est de ne pas être
dans les deux lignes en même temps et
d'être un coup d'enzyme un coup d'enzag
vous n'imaginez pas première ministre la
dernière première ministre du
quinquennat j'en sais rien moi c'est pas
moi qui suis président de la République
donc c'est à François Hollande face à
Man
uel Vallat pour lui faire barrage
vous savez deux ans et demi c'est très
long d'ici d'ici 2017 on sait pas ce qui
se passera seulement des Français
veulent que François Hollande se
représente en 2017 est-ce qu'il est
disqualifié
c'est à lui de répondre il faut qu'il
amène nous interroge il faut qu'il
améliore les sondages c'est
effectivement au moins lorsque il y aura
la désignation il a simplement 17% qui
veulent qui se représente je le vois pas
se représenter donc à lui de travailler
aujourd'hui pour que tout le monde se
dise ah finalement on s'est redressé
d'un point de vue économique cela donne
du travail de chômage des ministres etc
quand vous faites cet énumération Gérard
Collomb moi je crois toujours que tout
est possible cela dépend de la volonté
des hommes donc je suis quelqu'un de
très volontariste quand l'entourage de
François Hollande personne ne veut d'une
primaire c'est pourtant dans les statuts
du PS vous en souhaiteriez une
je ne vois pas comment un moment donné
on ne pourrait pas avoir
une compétition qui soit qui soit
ouverte pour désigner le candidat de
2017 mais en même temps les choses se
feront d'elles-mêmes soit on est dans la
même situation économique et sociale
franchement ça sera difficile pour tout
le monde je suis même pas sûr que tout
le monde se batte pour aller à la
primaire ou en tout cas
oui mais ils le feront pour 2020 ils le
feront pour 2020 pour se positionner sur
2020 voilà exactement et donc soit on
est dans une situation différente et les
choses peuvent encore se redresser je
voyais les premiers premiers éléments
intéressants 1 le coût du travail qui
est pour la première fois sur le
deuxième semestre 2014 était passé
derrière les coûts du travail allemand
du fait de
du cice et donc du pacte de stabilité
deux
sur une analyse de
rexécode on voyait que le nombre
d'entreprises qui avaient fermées par
rapport à celle qui était ouverte même
si on est toujours dans la négative ça
s'était restreint donc on voit quelques
signes qui pourraient nous dire que
quelque part on pourrait effectivement
retourner la situation économique pour
être représenter si les choses
s'améliorent
quand au départ j'ai été candidat à la
mairie de Lyon en 2001 si vous aviez
soupesé les chances que j'avais au
départ personne me donnait une chance à
l'époque et voilà ça s'est passé donc
vous voyez tout est toujours possible
parce que vous comprenez l'abstention
des frondeurs à l'Assemblée nationale
sur le budget qui prévoit quand même la
suppression de la première tranche
d'imposition de l'impôt sur le revenu si
vous voulez moi sur la première tranche
d'imposition c'est là où je vous dis
qu'il faut être quand même dans les
mesures je m'aperçois que la première
tranche d'imposition ça coûte
3,7 milliards de manque de recettes donc
à l'état et pour les collectivités
locales cette année on va baisser leur
dotation de 3,2 milliards et grosso modo
on est au même chiffre ça veut dire que
la le manque de recettes il est pas
financé par l'État il va être financé
par les baisses de dotation des
collectivités locales et nous dans
quelques semaines pour faire nos budgets
on va être dans des situations
extrêmement difficiles vos difficultés
dans un instant donc vous déplorez cette
suppression de la première tranche mais
je dis quand généralement ce n'est pas à
être financé par les collectivités
territoriales
dernière question justement toutes ces
expressions de Martine Aubry les
expressions des frondeurs ça c'est du
pain béni pour la droite qui
oui mais d'un autre côté il s'en donne
aussi à cœur joie voyez toutes les
histoires autour de Bygmalion tout ça se
fait pas non plus extraordinaire
Sarkozy François Fillon a pu à la Juvet
l'équation avec le Front national il
s'agira d'être au second tour
j'aimerais autant que le Front national
ne soit pas au second tour ça veut dire
que les parties républicains doivent
pouvoir avoir un langage qui ne soit pas
totalement déconnecté des actes parce
que c'est ce qui tue aujourd'hui la
crédibilité politique des uns comme des
autres merci Karine alors on a parlé
vous avez rendu hommage tout à l'heure
au début de cette émission à Christophe
de Marjorie est-ce que vous avez honte
parfois d'être dans un parti et de
cohabiter avec quelqu'un comme Gérard
fil oche qui est membre du bureau
national et qui a parlé de l'ancien
patron de Total comme d'un de
sang d'un grand féodal
oui c'est pas bien d'abord
le discours
vous me la prenez mais on parle pas
comme ça quoi ça c'est clair que on ne
s'exprime pas comme ceci merci encore
une fois Karine à suivre donc Perrine
terno depuis Xena qui nous rejoint on va
voir donc un aspect de l'arrivée
politique de réforme qui suscite des
réserves chez vous vous venez de les
exprimer c'est bien sûr la baisse des
dotations publiques alors avec quelles
conséquences par exemple et bien le
reportage à Lyon est dans le Grand Lyon
de Louis Sibille
c'est un coup de rabot de l'État dont ce
serait bien passé le Grand Lyon
160 millions d'euros de moins en 2015
plus qu'une goutte d'eau dans l'océan
d'un budget qui s'élève à 2 milliards
d'euros et qui oblige à de sérieuses
coupes peut-être faudra-t-il se résoudre
à fermer certains équipements comme
comme des Maisons de l'Enfance comme
comme ce genre d'équipement mais là
encore rien n'est arbitré disons qu'il
faut qu'on trouve des des réductions qui
ne vont pas conduire la population à un
certain désespoir par suppression de
d'équipements nécessaires ironie du sort
à Lyon l'opposition est d'accord avec le
gouvernement la collectivité peut faire
mieux avec moins en tant responsable de
l'opposition depuis des années on
demande à ce que cette baisse d'État sur
publique soit anticipée et en fait elle
ne l'est pas on aurait pu s'en occuper
plus tôt et s'en occupait plutôt ça
voulait dire réduire les frais de
fonctionnement ça voulait dire faire des
choix plus pertinents en matière
d'investissement et notamment faire des
qui rapporte pour faire des économies la
mairie prévoit aussi d’investir moins
mais c'est le grand lion qui va en pâtir
le plus les commandes de travaux publics
vont chuter de 40% chantiers phares
l'extension de la gare Part-Dieu ou
encore le tronçon ouest du périphérique
pourrait prendre du retard sur
l'investissement
évidemment il y a des capacités encore
sur le Grand Lyon liés en particulier au
fait que le il y a un faible taux
d'endettement donc si la communauté
urbaine future métropole devait
développer des projets structurants pour
l'agglo elle pourrait le faire notamment
sur la base de l'emprunt parce que la
situation de la communauté urbaine de ce
point de vue là SN la baisse des
dotations intervient au mauvais moment
pour le budget du Grand Lyon à partir de
janvier prochain la communauté urbaine
récupère les compétences du Conseil
général un transfert qui a un coût pas
encore chiffré par la mairie
voilà Perrine d'Arnaud nous a rejoint
bonsoir Perrine on a senti dans le
reportage quand même une solidarité
droite-gauche à un face à la situation
c'est le consensus peut-être à la
lyonnaise
effectivement comment rationaliser les
dépenses en période de disette à quoi
vous allez devoir renoncer cette année
et dans les années qui suivent au cours
de votre mandat d'abord qu'est-ce qu'on
a fait on avait un peu anticipé parce
que ça fait un certain temps que l'on
voit on va dire que que l'État s'est
endetté de manière extraordinaire et
donc il va à un moment donné tailler
dans les dotations et comme vous le
savez à Lyon on a créé la métropole de
Lyon pour fusionner le conseil général
et la communauté urbaine de manière
rationalisée la dépense et de mettre de
faire des économies dans un premier
temps la maison
vous avez jamais rien qui permettent de
réaliser des économies en l'espace
de 6 mois mais nous espérons bien que
sur la durée cela va nous permettre de
réduire effectivement un certain nombre
de dépenses je pense que dans les deux
trois ans qu'est-ce qu'on va faire par
exemple on a aujourd'hui deux services
de voirie sur le territoire on va plus
en avoir qu'un alors évidemment on va
pas renvoyer les gens mais ça veut dire
qu'on va pas remplacer les départs à la
retraite et donc petit à petit la taille
du service va pouvoir se restreindre par
rapport aux deux services qu'il y avait
de manière initiale et je pourrais vous
citer différents secteurs où on va
réaliser la même chose ça c'est la
rationalisation territoriale là
justement la réforme territoriale qui
revient en discussion au Sénat à partir
de la semaine prochaine sur notamment le
redécoupage des régions que
d'aller-retour du gouvernement depuis
deux ans qui a beaucoup de tergiverser
sur le sujet d'une part est-ce qu'on a
perdu trop de temps et d'autre part
Manuel Valls qui va s'exprimer ici au
Sénat le 28 octobre vous en attendez
quoi qu'est-ce que vous attendez de
nouveau de la part du gouvernement qu'il
populaire justement sur ce dossier si
vous voulez c'est un dossier compliqué
d'autant plus compliqué que quand le
Parti socialiste est dans l'opposition
et que on va dire le gouvernement veut
faire une réforme des collectivités
territoriales le PS explique que c'est
affreux que jamais on a vu ça et vice
versa quand c'est le parti socialiste
qui est au gouvernement l'UMP explique
c'est affreux ce qui se passe pour les
collectivités locales donc la réforme
est extrêmement difficile mais est-ce
qu'elle est impossible non puisque nous
nous le faisons je crois qu'à un moment
donné il faut sortir
et on l'a fait passer dans la loi
puisqu'elle a été adoptée je vous
rappelle au Sénat par exemple au Sénat
elle a été adoptée par tous les groupes
sauf le Parti communiste donc on a
réussi à dépasser les contradictions et
je pense que justement ce consensus
droit de gauche pourrait à nouveau être
trouvé en tout cas c'est la volonté du
nouveau
faire et moi je disais l'autre jour vous
étiez là puisque c'est vous qui le
faisiez l'interview je disais il faut
essayer que il y ait une opposition
constructive et donc pas faire qu'on ne
fasse ici que de l'opposition au
gouvernement mais de tracer une ligne et
ensuite d'essayer de trouver des
éléments de convergence le principal
frein c'est quoi le corporatisme des
élus selon vous tous ces blocages dans
leur réforme territoriales
corporatisme en même temps si évolue si
vous voulez l'évolution par exemple
économique des territoires avec des
régions qui sont en grande difficulté
avec d'autres qui vivent de l'économie
résidentielle donc des transferts de
l'État qui craignent des diminutions
c'est évidemment plus facile de faire
une réforme quand vous êtes en période
de croissance que quand vous êtes en
période de difficulté voilà absolument
mais on a quand on a eu l'impression de
ces derniers temps d'une espèce de
grande braderie braderie notamment avec
les revendications des Radicaux de
Gauche Jean-Michel Bailey qui demandait
à ce que un certain nombre de
départements reste
soient maintenu il a obtenu gain de
cause 50 départements au moins maintenu
50 départements ruraux qu'est-ce que
vous en pensez négociation là si vous
voulez bonne les négociations je trouve
ça bon limite mais
limite sur la façon de présenter les
choses moi j'ai toujours
défendu une thèse relativement claire
c'est que la France pouvait plus être
organisée de manière uniforme et donc
qui avait à la fois les métropoles qu'il
fallait faire rayonner par rapport au
métropole européenne qui avait le cas de
l'Île-de-France qu'il fallait un peu
simplifier puis qui avait le cas
effectivement des départements ruraux
n'existaient pas de grandes métropoles
et qu'il fallait traiter comme quelque
chose de particulier donc sur le fond
les propositions de Bailey ne me choque
pas ce qui est évidemment fait quand
même un peu théâtrale c'est la forme
c'est la forme espèce de chantage mais
quand même le lobby département ici au
scénario il est particulièrement bien
représenté et défendu un peu trop non
mais quand quand moi j'avais présenté il
y a maintenant 7-8 ans l'idée de
métropole ici au Sénat ça avait fait
sursauter tout le monde je crois que on
en parlait comme d'un espèce d'OVNI qui
tout d'un coup apparaissait puis petit à
petit l'idée a fait son chemin donc je
pense que on peut effectivement toujours
aller dans le sens du mouvement
simplement faut un peu de volonté de
ténacité et de courage Gérard Larcher le
nouveau président du Sénat obtenu le
report du second texte sur le transfert
des compétences entre les collectivités
territoriales est-ce que ça signifie que
finalement on reporte aussi d'autant
l'application concrète de cette réforme
territoriale
il y a déjà une réforme qui est passée
sur la loi lamaptam sur donc les
métropoles c'est la dernière qui est
passé donc je vous rappelle que ça
le tabac département région etc pour le
moment évidemment que
dans un certain nombre de cas la réforme
est reportée c'est pas vrai surtout que
les métropoles puisque aujourd'hui on
dit par exemple à ce qui est écrit dans
la loi c'est que par exemple par rapport
au département toutes les villes qui
seront devenues métropoles pourront
prendre trois des sept compétences qui
sont celles des conseils généraux
aujourd'hui mais ça c'est l'exception un
peu pour les métropoles est-ce que dans
ce contexte quand même territorial
donc c'est important en matière de
produits intérieur brut par exemple de
production de richesse c'est quand même
pas tout à fait on va se grosso modo 40
à 50% plus c'est 60% du Pipe de la
France est-ce que quand même dans ce
contexte territorial de réforme est-ce
qu'il faudrait selon vous décaler les
dates des élections locales pour
l'instant les départementales prévus en
mars 2015 et les régionales en décembre
écoutez on est déjà donc
décalé moi je pense qu'à un moment donné
il va falloir quand même avancer on peut
pas reporter un défi ces élections tous
les élus régionaux
de l'agglomération lyonnaise je ne
crains pas puisqu'on a supprimé les
conseillers générations
de manière générale au niveau national
oui bien sûr qu'il va y avoir
des difficultés c'est ces lettres et je
veux dire que peut-être qu'il y a une
confiance justement dans la fin du
quinquennat sur le fait que reporter
vers la fin du quinquennat ça permettra
d'avoir amélioré la situation économique
et sociale et donc tout ira bien à ce
moment-là un petit
module Gérard Larcher pour présenter son
programme d'action pour les trois années
qui arrivent Gérard Larcher qui qui a
beaucoup répété que l'institution Sénat
était menacée dans son utilité dans sa
crédibilité est-ce que vous pensez vous
aussi que ça disparition est programmée
je ne pense pas je pense que on a besoin
effectivement de représentants des
collectivités territoriales et moi j'ai
toujours dit que mon modèle c'était le
modèle allemand avec le Bundes tag et le
bundo straat le Bundes qui représente
donc l'Assemblée du peuple
c'est limité mais important c'est à dire
que le Bundes sera n'examine que les
lois qui ont un impact sur le
fonctionnement des collectivités
territoriales mais ça veut dire par
exemple regarder ma baisse des dotations
il faudrait si on était en Allemagne qui
est un accord entre le Bundes strat et
le Bundes strike
ça serait quelque chose finalement
d'assez innovant vous étiez opposé à la
loi sur la limitation du cumul des
mandats en 2017 vous allez devoir
choisir entre votre mandat de sénateur
représenter là donc on verra en 2017 on
verra en 2017
il va falloir choisir il voulait pas
dire aujourd'hui
je ferai une autre émission avec vous
spécialement pour cela vous avez parlé
tout à l'heure de de métropoles que vous
associez à nouveau rayonnement en espace
c'est vrai aussi pour les personnes qui
sont à leur tête comme vous si on vous
demandait d'entrer au gouvernement
choisir là je suis en plein en pleine
réalisation de la métropole donc d'abord
personne me demande rien peut-être
justement parce que j'ai une ligne qui
est trop engagée donc ça peut être vous
êtes un peu pénalisé dans votre carrière
éventuelle
ce que je sais c'est qu'au partis
socialiste j'ai rarement été dans une
majorité rayonnante
au sport qui était député un bureau nus
plein d’être à peine rentré au
gouvernement que pouf déjà son siège de
débuter serait convoité par votre femme
paraît-il c'est vrai qu'elle serait
candidate aux législatives
qui devrait essayer de réfléchir
térébraya c'est faire de bonnes réformes
gouvernementales pour qu'en 2017 les
Lyonnais soit tellement satisfaits qu'il
le plébiscite au niveau local mais ce
qu'il sera encore candidat parce que
votre femme
plus d'autre chose
directement je vais l'envoyer faire une
émission d'accord mais là des ambitions
elle a des ambitions politiques puisque
si je m'abuse et ça on n'a pas beaucoup
à Lyon elle a été nommée à la tête de la
section
socialiste du 5e arrondissement
quand on est nommé à la tête de la
section
à l'unanimité en plus
socialiste c'est que forcément il y a un
avenir devant soi je me demande même
elle ne le dit pas c'est mais si elle ne
vise pas les présidentielles
peut-être votre poste de sénateur ah
c'est possible
la réponse à cette question politique au
familiale qui occupe Lyon en ce moment
merci beaucoup merci merci
Monsieur Collon et la semaine prochaine
notre invité sera le ministre de
l'Intérieur Bernard Cazeneuve bonsoir à
tous et à très vite